I want you think about the number 198
198 198 players that were drafted before
Tom Brady think about this two thousand
and a full draft he is picked number 199
comes out of Michigan doesn't look good
well you look at his body you're kind of
like I just what it is and that draft I
want to say
levar Arrington was picked Peter Warrick
was on Dallas as a wide receiver from
Florida State Brian Urlacher was on that
list Jamal Lewis who once ran 295 yards
his record was broken by Adrian Peterson
296 he was on that list Jay Abrams on
Ellis Janikowski on that list Chad
Pennington was the first quarterback and
this guy was picked 199 we're not
talking like xx 199 is when he was
picked now I want you think about this
year they're saying you're gonna retire
you're gonna do this he wins a six
championship they I'm not even a Brady
fan I'm not a New England Patriots fan I
was a die-hard Buffalo Bills thumb when
I came here from Iran I was a Thurman
Thomas fan Don Beebe Bryce pop Ruth
Smith Jim Kelly that was my team that
was who I rooted form we you know these
guys they stabbed drew bledsoe drew
blood sure gets hurt he comes and he
steps up and then becomes Tom Brady when
six championships and 18 seasons and so
when you look at this this is what I
think about when I think about Tom Brady
there's a lot of ways you can say oh
he's the goat he's this he's that I
think is the goat of goats because it's
very difficult to do what he did in the
NFL but it's the part a lot of people
get into the NFL for the fame for the
prestige for the party and for the girls
oh man I'm gonna have so many different
girls every night it's gonna be a
different one dawg we gonna party like
there's no tomorrow no party like rock
stars right Fame I'm gonna be on TV
everybody from school is gonna see now
on TV look at me I'm famous look at the
change look at the cars look at the
jewelry that's another one Ryan the
other one is money I got a 40 million
dollar contract I'm making six million
you're eight million here look at this
look at that and it's some dude because
I want to be a pro bowler I want to win
a game I want to win a championship game
but very few are wired like this guy I
know what's crazy about a guy like him
no one finds out
who is the Brady of their league or
their industry for a long time nobody
does nobody does it takes 1020 years
sometimes 30 years to find that out in
the business world there's a lot of
people that come out of the gates and
they went fast in the sports world it's
the same thing in everything you'll
never know
10 20 years down the line know what's
crazy I remember one time I was in a
meeting and a guy speaking from stage
and I was probably the number 50 guy in
the company okay and nobody saw me as a
number-one guy or somebody that could
come up it's probably number 50 guy in
the company but I remember looking at
the speaker and never forget what I was
telling myself I said these guys have no
idea I am NOT gonna stop I'm not gonna
stop I don't think these guys understand
it I don't care about the lifestyle you
know why buy a car like this do you know
what I buy a car like this one when I
was a kid I saw the Shah with the
picture upside down in Iran when I went
to his museum he's eight castles that he
had this car was there and he drove a
Rolls and I told myself one day I'm
gonna buy because I'll tell my dad dad
look at our rules or as one day I'm
gonna buy that for myself I said come on
you know you're dreaming but honestly I
don't kid about this guy drive this
every day I put I put fifteen thousand
miles on this every year I don't buy
this like all oh my look at this exotic
I just park at he's robbing like it's a
Ford Contour this is a given for a guy
like Brady this is a given you know
sometimes if you're watching this
yourself and you're thinking Pat I don't
know how to describe this to you man I
gotta sleep and I wake up I just can't
stop dreaming about who I want to be in
life you know last night I was watching
my gladiator I can't stop watching
gladiator for my so that's like my it's
my drug when I watch it this story of
redemption nothing like it man when
nobody thinks he could pull it off when
everybody doubts you when everybody says
oh you'll never do it and you know it's
crazy all you guys that are watching
this somebody was oh my god just was the
exact message for me Pat
I don't know if it is let me tell you
why I don't know what time you woke up
today I don't know how fired up you are
today I don't know if you need the world
to motivate you every day cuz nobody
needs to motivate Brady every day
he doesn't need a motivational speaker
to get him gone yeah I make these videos
but these videos are built for you to
eventually not need it anymore
it isn't built for you the constant
thing needed it's built for you to
finally realize how to motivate yourself
and by the way the majority need it
constantly but the view you have a
vision in your brain you can't take it
out we can't take it out you can't take
it out somebody they don't believe in
you somebody says you can't do it
somebody said there's no way in the
world you are you out of your mind you
could never do this you don't have a
degree you don't come from the right
family you were broke you're poor you're
an accent not that smart
you need that good it's no way you'll
pull it off and all of those things stay
in your brain you know how many scenes
of conversations are recorded on my
brain you know how many you got you guys
have to live with them and know they're
right or the few of you that are
watching this very small percentage less
than 1% of you that are watching this
less than 1% you can't take it out and
you can't live your life without seeing
those things become a reality you know
who you are you know exactly who you are
because this messaging message resonates
with you so 198 never been a rated fan
never was a drew bledsoe fan more than I
was a Brady family came out of
Washington State but look at this guy
unbelievable what this guy's done this
whole story today is not about him it's
by you what are you doing it for fame
the money cars like this the lifestyle
freedom or to get a taste of what it's
like to be the best in your world in
your industry knowing when the guy takes
a day off you're going knowing the day
your competitor gets casual you're
doubling down on effort it's a big
difference by the way no one know Brady
was gonna be who he was he didn't look
like a professional football player he
looks more in shape today than he did
when I first came into the league but
you can't read someone's heart man you
cannot measure someone's heart you
cannot so anyways if you follow a story
you know how special it is
if you don't they're one of the greatest
underdog stories of all time another
great example of talent is good you
can't measure heart now he also ended up
having a great mentor by the way that
wanted as bad as soon if not more you
put those two together unstoppable
combination so this week after watching
this video what are you doing it for
fame money prestige freedom glory or to
find out what it's like to be one of the
best if not the best in your industry
actually ask that question for yourself
if you're still watching this video
right now if you're not distracted with
all the other things that are aren't you
and if it fires you up and you're saying
Pat I fully relate to everything you're
saying well then guess what when
everything goes wrong this week when
your appointment cancels when your best
sales canceled when your best customer
cancels when your mom is disappointed
cuz you haven't called her back when
your girl breaks up with you and your
boyfriend breaks up with you when
something bad happens to your business
to you on the market your family to your
friends that's when you realize if you
really got to get it and then we'll have
to find out if you can last
five 10 15 20 years that's when we found
out about your stamina your fatigue your
endurance everybody Lanza and a few of
you that stick around the world's gonna
know about you
it's just how these things work anyways
I hope this message resonates with those
few of you that actually think about
this all day long let's have a killer
week everybody take care love you bye